yeah thank you very much jessica for
your
nice introduction
um
yeah um
my name is
hannah as
i'm a former scientist
in neuroscience phd and i'm now working
as a data scientist and software
developer at a small company called
intlic io
now that i'm a data scientist i
often get contacted by former colleagues
and
neuroscientists all around the world to
ask me
i want to transition how did you do that
so
this talk is for you it's for all the
academics who are thinking about leaving
i would like to outline my personal
journey and also as a bonus i included
everything i wish i had known when i was
searching for my first job in industry
so um if you scan this qr code you will
go to the my website and
i
prepared a little website with all like
resources that i will mention during my
talk
and um yeah
go there there's lots of stuff yet you
you what you will
might find helpful
and i will show the link on my last
slide again if you miss it now
um before i
introduce myself and tell you um why i
left academia i would like to know um
who is currently here in academia and
thinking about leaving
oh a lot of people
and who is um in industry but has left
already
oh also like half
um and is there anybody in industry like
um currently um
hiring people from academia
ah yeah nice so go to them talk to them
after the talk
[Laughter]
one more
yeah
great
yeah this is me
i'm working as a data scientist
at implicio we
built end-to-end data solutions
with the focus on geospatial data
from front-end to back-end like
everything web platforms apps
dashboards
and i was
before
until 2020 2020 i was
in academia for nearly 10 years
this is a picture i took off my head and
my brain during my last postdoc position
when a
participant didn't show up in the mri
scanner so we had like some free time
and could play around um
yeah i during my phd i specialized in
analyzing functional magnetic resonance
imaging data like fmri
um and
um yeah and then
during my post-doc i was also in the in
the lab at uni
university potsdam where i was
yeah
analyzing brain data mainly and in a
brain research group
and i really loved my job um i like i
really loved doing research um
like uh collecting data in an mri was
like frying flying a rocket
it was really great um also like making
up questions um which you can solve with
data and
um
writing
journal papers and like really diving
into um
into the topics
but i think always like the best part
was when i could like walk out of the
mri machine with my hard drive with all
the brain data and go to my office and
analyze it which was like
the best part
um
so but when i was um offered an
extension of my contract it was like
a fixed term contract like most
contracts in academia
i um still had with mixed feelings
because it was
my actually my 13th
fixed term contract in academia
i had to count it because my german
pension insurance asked me to
recently um so um
yeah
and and and if you're in an academia you
will know the act of fixed term um
employments in academia in germany so it
basically means that after six years
after you finish your phd you have to
get a permanent position because then
it's very difficult to get like
extensions for your contracts
and then i was like okay um
it's going to be more difficult
um and the only
what what can i do i have to become a
professor but
um like becoming a professor is very
competitive and for me it was like okay
um
being a professor is not like is more
going to meetings teaching and
what i like most is like analyze data
like and do research and this is not
something that you like normally do as a
professor it's like a different career
like a different job
and um
when i was like thinking about this um
then i stumbled across an um opportunity
on the prosthetic
postdoc graduate school website and they
offered
career coaching by career coach
to pay for that and i
went there and
i think it was meant to like
to go there to enhance your academic
academic career but after the first
appointment i i already knew that i
wanted to leave academia for good so
um
then i was there and i was like okay
i
read this on twitter recently
by a doctor female former academic she
writes
we've never been told that the academic
career path is only one of the many
possibilities from phd to prof that's
what we've been told but when you're out
suddenly there are myriads of
possibilities yet you're not trained to
pick the path you want
and i think this is some something like
many people know from academia it's it's
like we we are working in a bubble and
there's not
not so many connections to industry at
least in my field i think in it that's a
bit different but in neuroscience it's
like that
so
where
would i start so i was like really
overwhelmed at the beginning
and so
i would say
if you ask me now
start like this um i i would ask um
yourself like three simple but i think
also very difficult questions
um and they are what do you want
what do you bring
and what do you need to learn and
to find out i think it's it's difficult
because at the beginning it feels like
everybody is asking you
what cake do you want to bake and you
don't have a recipe book and you don't
have
any idea about the stocks you have
available
so
um i would start like the what do you
want question i would start with
reading like job ads they are a bit like
a recipe book
um
and then
talk to people outside academia as much
as you can
um and
i would recommend to start applying as
soon as possible and don't wait for your
dream dream job but just
start applying because for me it was a
very good
opportunity to
get acquainted with the job market and
to talk to people
outside academia to talk to data
scientists and to people who hire data
scientists they can tell you a lot about
the job and the everyday life and
um for me it was like really helpful
um
i will go through the questions now one
by one and tell you a little bit more
about it
and so what do you want
i think the first thing
which i find like really really
important is to make a decision whether
you want to stay or whether you want to
leave
because i think if you want to stay you
can you have to put all your effort in
becoming like making a career in
academia um
and you have to be decided and
i think if you really want to become a
professor you can you definitely become
a professor you can do that but
if you don't and if you're undecided i
think you should also make the decision
to leave as soon as possible which
doesn't mean that you necessarily have
to quit your job immediately but just
shift your focus from like writing the
next peer-reviewed journal paper at the
first author to like building a network
outside academia
and then
i would recommend to
get as specific as you can be like um
what you want
and at the beginning it it will be
difficult
um but ask like your motivation if
you're here at pycon you will probably
already be programming and love
programming so that's a perfect start
but even as a python developer you have
like still have myriads of possibilities
and then yeah
ask yourself what you like and what
makes you forget time what you like to
program
and then also i would recommend to be
also specific with your boundaries
um because as a for me
for for example
i am located in berlin i'm based here
and i don't want to relocate for my job
so at the beginning i was like
um can i really share that will it like
lower my my job chances and now in
retrospective i think it is really
important to share your boundaries
because it will make it easier for you
to find your dream job or the job that
you like
and it will also make it easier for the
company to find somebody who's a match
and who is like really
the one they want to hire so
don't try to like please everyone
everyone
and then the next question what do you
bring
it's also closely connected i think
um
at the beginning also like the data
roles will be like really confusing um
for me they were like confusing and
there's a very nice webinar by ai guild
which you find on on youtube and on my
website um
which gives a very good overview um over
the the definitions of like and the
skill set that is required for these
data roles
but always keep in mind that the
different companies they have different
interpretations of the data roles and it
also differs if the company is small or
big so in smaller companies you are
more often like doing like everything
and it's less specified like in bigger
companies
and then if you have like an idea like
which role you are interested in then
you can look at your skill set and think
about what do they already bring
and and in my experience um academics
tend to underestimate the abilities they
already have
so you will be probably pro programming
um
you will
be trained in analytical thinking you
know how to solve problems you know how
to work independently you might have
even been working with data so um write
everything and highlight it in your cv
um
yeah and then adjust your cv i think
this is like a
very big topic which i could like give
another talk about
um
because like cvs and industry and and
academia are like really different
um um i would just like to show you just
like through the three top differences
uh for me
so this is um
my cv that i used to apply for my last
postdoc position it's like um i put
like many of the the contracts i had um
i started with the education part
on top
yeah i put my publication in it's a very
long cv
so and this is the one i use now
as you can see
the professional experience is one of
the the most important parts
and
also the technical skills
and
if you are applying for a job highlight
everything that might be interesting for
them and uh try to like adapt to
the the the communication style like um
of the companies
and if you have a gift github profile
include the github profile in in your um
yeah and make it short not longer than
one page
um but yeah um
talk to people outside academia
and get help because i think at the
beginning it's very difficult to to know
how to do it
okay and then what to learn
um
i think this yeah it definitely depends
on what you bring and what you want to
do so um you might have like a data role
in mind that really interests you a lot
and then if you see like your skill set
maybe you want to become a data engineer
you see that you like missing some
knowledge on cloud infrastructure and
you you decide to learn that then i
would like really
recommend to document everything on your
github like if you have a github in in
industry it's very important it's a bit
like
a business card or portfolio so um it's
a big bonus if you have one and if you
if you can show something
um
make a project that you like always
wanted to do or like use the taste deck
that you really really want to show and
um
and include a nice readme so people
actually
immediately see what you're doing and
why why you were doing it
and it will be really helpful
and then
a career in tech is less about learning
a specific tool as it is the willingness
to learn a different tool when the time
comes um don't like
think that you have to like know
everything when you like when you move
into industry because um
you will have to learn like different
tools anyway
just i would
you will probably have enough just to
start and then
get going because that's like everybody
what's everybody what everybody is doing
so
um
oh yeah and then my favorite part is
become part of your new community
um
i would
really say go and attend meetups and
get involved with the with the community
or do you want to
get into um so when i left like my job
actually it was january 2020 so one
month before the pandemic and i already
was involved in my in the community and
i was so happy that i was like there
were like
people that i already knew and um they
were like noah and kat they offered me
to a online bootcamp which they did like
for free and um it was really helpful
for me
it's also very helpful to find travel
companions so
other people who
were looking for a job which you can
peer program with or do a project
together and
encourage each other each other and then
consider continue contributing to open
source
um i think this is like a really
great way to give something back to the
community and to like we we have to to
um improve the tools that we use and
it's great if you like if you contribute
to that
and um
marin here she is um
doing um sprints pi lady sprints for
under
underrepresented groups in at pi ladies
um and also um data umbrella is doing
like
sprints online and um yeah if you saw
the talk by rashma yesterday um and it
will be on youtube you will find like
lots of uh resources to how to get
started
and then yeah get involved in in twitter
i personally love twitter there's also a
big community of former academics
and there's one slack channel founded by
dr nicole betts
and it's called moving on from academia
i also included a link on my website
it's a nice it's a nice community on
slack with people who like who are
leaving not only to tech um jobs but
anywhere from academia
yeah and then talk to people as much as
you can
about your job search
and um because also the hidden job
market it's like i think 85 percent of
the jobs are not on and like they don't
even have an ad so um it's just worth
about two mouth and this is actually how
i found my job as well it was like on
a i guild slack channel my boss
he promoted a boot camp actually and for
academics and i called him i told him
i don't need a boot camp i just want to
work for you and
yeah he hired me like on the spot i
didn't even do an interview
and not not a technical challenge
yeah and it's a good opportunity to talk
about your salaries ex like if you ask
nicely um it's um people you will find
people who can do you will tell you what
they what they earn and it's a very good
start so if because in an interview you
will be asked about your salary
expectations and it's good to have an
idea so what you what you what people
earn in in industry like in the job that
you want to do
um yeah and then finally i would
recommend
to get in referrals so because i didn't
know anything about that when i was
leaving academia um referrals mean that
if you are working in a company in tech
it's often that if you refer somebody
and he is actually hired that you get a
bonus
and it can be like just
a bottle of champagne but it can also be
like
um several thousand euro
so um this if you ask for a referral
this is not this is like a win-win
situation um possibly so you can get it
you get a job and they get a bonus so
yeah ask for referrals
um
yeah and um
the year is 2032 97 of 97 of former
academics are now employed as a data
scientist
well we will see in 10 years maybe
um
i am like really happy now as a data
scientist i'm like really enjoy my my
job i can do what i always wanted to do
like analyze data and
um
i can like like now i have i have a
permanent uh contract and i can like
really uh dive into it and focus on like
enjoying my my work and getting better
what of and what i actually do so
um i totally recommend it five stars and
yeah
if you um
[Music]
yeah
do it
become a data analyst data scientist
data engineer
um yeah and i would like to to thank all
the great communities worldwide and um
and in berlin um
and and these are um this is my company
in blick and um
uh also especially the pie ladies and
women in machine learning and data
science and
all the people who make it happen i'm
really
really grateful
and
especially to these
communities i feel like really connected
thank you
[Applause]
and i think i say on behalf of everyone
thank you thank you wow what a great uh
talk and uh i didn't come from academia
but i resonated a lot with things that
you were saying so i
really appreciated it i'm just getting
the questions up now if you have
questions please pop them into slido
um
and you can also vote on them to let me
know which ones you want me to go with
first
so there we go just reviewed so here we
go
once at your first non-academic job
what should you do first
oh that's an interesting question
um
yeah i think it's like
in every job you i think you should
listen first what your like co-workers
um tell you and um yeah try to
um get connected to the work that you
are actually
um going to do
yeah that's a great tip it's a good
it's good to know who to ask the
questions to yeah also maybe you can add
something to that if yeah i think this
is a good answer of like you know find
out who is in charge of which domain and
who can give you the answers you need so
that you know who you need to go speak
to when you're given something and you
need to find out more yeah
so
do applications with referrals have
higher priority to get a job call from a
company in your experience
i don't know
anything about like internally but
i think it's a very good opportunity for
the company because um if they're if
you're like referring somebody from your
network they are like more likely to
have like a similar qualification
and and it i think it is also very
difficult for the companies at the
moment to find like um
skilled people and it's just also they
will just be happy to to have have
people applying
yeah yeah i agree i i think it does help
also
yeah in my experience
um especially potentially like if your
um background is slightly different to
the role that you're applying for i
think having a referral
actually gives you a great advantage so
i think your tips there were
spot on actually
i wish i had known that yeah me too
i'm okay here's a very popular question
um do you think that age is a factor in
the industry for employment
i think it's everywhere no
um
[Music]
yeah that's why i would also recommend
to leave as early as possible
if you already know that
good or bad about it it's just yours
is there anything you missed from
academia then what i miss yeah what what
do you miss
like um
sometimes it was like just working
without like having like a real plan
like to explore and like have time to
explore and you try a tool and it
doesn't work getting that take another
one
but um
yeah it's it's it's not something i
really miss it's just something i
also did and it was fun yeah yeah fair
enough
i'm okay so someone is asking what was
the salary that you asked for
i don't know if that's a very
appropriate question yeah but um maybe
in a more abstract form um do you have
any regrets regarding that so like i
think what you highlighted was
understanding what you're worth
which is really important to know what
you're worth um and did you feel like
there was any negatives for you and that
experience of navigating
negotiating and understanding your worth
um
maybe as a career changer in that sense
yeah i think it is difficult especially
as a career changer but um yeah but
there's like still room for improvement
and that's okay
so
there's also a lot of good websites that
give you estimates around what different
roles get paid
um and yeah if you come to meetups and
talk to people they're normally
one-on-one
it's okay we don't mind to share like i
think it's really important to normalize
sharing about salary
um
probably would also not feel that
comfortable saying
good one for trying
how could companies attract academics
more efficiently do you think
um
yeah i think
it's it's
what i i had the feeling that the
companies they didn't really know what
they could expect from academics and i
think if you like
ask the people like
already working maybe in your company
there will be lots of academics and um
maybe
get them on board for the hiring
procedure because it
yeah
i think it's like one of the biggest
obstacles is that
there we don't like really have like
good understanding of like what industry
does and what academia does and um
we lack this connection and if there
would be a better connection it would be
like really helpful
yeah great point yeah
i think um
we're also at the place where i'm
working we're also actually working with
the um pht and
tu
universities here in berlin
and i've really noticed like i don't
have an academic background at all but i
really noticed like the different ways
of working in the different
understanding
so i think yeah
a company that has someone like yourself
who's already made that transition
actually is probably in a really good
position to attract more academics yes
because you understand how to onboard
people how to get the most work to their
strengths
fantastic thank you so much hannah and
for such an interesting talk and yeah
please join me in a round of applause
thank you
[Applause]